>> Laura: THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED LAST
NIGHT THAT THE 2020 U.S. CENSUS
WILL INCLUDE A QUESTION ABOUT
CITIZENSHIP.
MAKES SENSE, RIGHT?
IT SEEMS PERFECTLY REASONABLE
FOR THE U.S. GOVERNMENT TO WANT
TO KNOW HOW MANY CITIZENS LIVE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
HERE IS HOW FAR LEFT IMMIGRATION
AND THE NOMADIC ACTIVISTS
REACTED.
SPEAK WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO DO
IS TO WEAPONIZE THE SENSES SO
THAT THEY CAN USE IT TO
UNDERCOUNTER PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STATES WITH
HIGH IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS.
>> THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
INCLUDING PRESIDENT TRUMP, HAS
TO JUSTIFY WHAT HE WOULD BE
WEAKENING ANY TYPE OF CENSUS
COUNT OR CENSUS STANDARDS.
>> IT IS VERY CLEAR WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO DO.
THEY ARE TRYING TO INSTILL FEAR
IN THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY.
>> Laura: I LOVE THE COMMENT
ABOUT THE RULE OF LAW.
THAT'S RICH.
NATURALLY, THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FILED A
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
IT IS AT LEAST THE 27TH TIME THE
GOLDEN STATE HAS SUED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, INCLUDING OVERT
DACA, THE TRAVEL BAN, THE BOARD
OF ALL, PRETTY MUCH ANY TIME THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BURPS THEY
GET A LAWSUIT.
TO DEBATE THIS IS CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSMAN FRED SHERMAN, WHO IS
A DEMOCRAT, CONGRESSMAN, FIRST
OF ALL, I WANT TO SAY, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US.
WE INVITE DEMOCRATS ON PRETTY
MUCH EVERY NIGHT AND MOST
DECLINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE LOVE HAVING A SPIRITED
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
HERE'S MY FIRST QUESTION.
>> LAURA, IT'S GOOD TO BE WITH
YOU.
BUT FIRST I NEED TO CORRECT THE
BEGINNING OF YOUR SHOW.
>> Laura: OH, I LOVE -- NO,
WE'RE NOT CORRECTING THAT.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON THIS FIRST.
YOU CAN WORRY ABOUT CORRECTING
ME LATER.
LET'S KEEP US FOCUSED ON
CITIZENSHIP.
WHY ARE DEMOCRATS AFRAID OF THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT DETERMINING HOW
MANY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE IN
THE UNITED STATES?
SPEAK UP FIRST OF ALL, THIS
CENSUS QUESTION HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH HOW MANY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY DON'T ASK WHETHER YOU ARE
AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
IT'S WHETHER YOU ARE AN
IMMIGRANT.
SECOND, WE WANT TO KNOW SO THERE
IS NO ATTEMPT TO DETERMINE THAT.
>> Laura: WE WANT TO KNOW WHO
IS A CITIZEN --
>> AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS IS
CLEAR.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS IS TO
SUPPRESS NOT ONLY IMMIGRANTS
FROM RESPONDING BUT ANYBODY WHO
HAS GOT A COUSIN WHO IS AN
IMMIGRANT.
THE STUDIES HAVE SHOWN, FROM THE
CENSUS DEPARTMENTS LAST YEAR,
UNDER TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, THAT
THIS QUESTION WILL DEPRESS
RESPONSES.
THIS IS A TWO-PART APPROACH.
FIRST CREATE A CREDIBLE
FIRST CREATE A CREDIBLE        I
FIRST CREATE A CREDIBLE        C
FIRST CREATE A CREDIBLE        E
FIRST CREATE A CREDIBLE        I
FIRST CREATE A CREDIBLE        L
FIRST CREATE A CREDIBLE        E
FIRST CREATE A CREDIBLE        F
FIRST CREATE A CREDIBLE        A
FIRST CREATE A CREDIBLE        R
IN IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES,
CASTIGATE THEM, CALL THEM
RAPISTS AND MURDERS.
>> Laura: ARE YOU DEFENDING
THE CRIMINALS THAT I TALKED
ABOUT?
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE DOING?
DEFENDING THE ABUSERS, THE
FENTANYL TRAFFICKERS?
I WILL DEBATE THAT MORNING,
NOON, AND NIGHT, LET'S DO AN
HOUR ON EL GORDO, LET'S TALK
ABOUT EL GORDO.
I MEAN, HONESTLY.
DEMOCRATS JUST LOSE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
YOU ARE MORE WORRIED ABOUT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THAN THE
LEGAL RESIDENTS OF YOUR OWN
COMMUNITIES, TIME AND AGAIN, AND
NOW YOU DON'T WANT US TO KNOW --
>> LAURA, ANY CHANCE I COULD GET
A WORD IN EDGE WISE?
>> Laura: AND THAT'S ANOTHER
TACTIC.
YES, YOU CAN, BUT DON'T START
COMING ON THE SHOW AND SAY, I'M
GOING TO CORRECT WHAT YOU SAID
IN THE FIRST SEGMENT.
WHAT I SAID WAS FACTUAL.
WE HAVE A CRIMINAL ALIEN
PROBLEM, AND YOUR STATE AS A
SANCTUARY DISASTER.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
GO AHEAD.
>> [SIGHS]
LAURA, YOU CAME ON, AND YOU
SHOWED THE PRESIDENT SAYING THAT
MOST IMMIGRANTS, ESPECIALLY FROM
MEXICO ARE RAPISTS AND
MURDERERS.
>> Laura: HE DIDN'T SAY THAT.
YOU TELL ME WHERE HE SAID
"MOST."
>> HE SAID THEY ARE RAPISTS AND
MURDERERS.
HIS FIRST CATEGORY RAPISTS, THE
SECOND CATEGORY MURDERERS, AND
IF YOU WERE A GOOD PEOPLE.
THAT IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID.
WHAT DID THE BEGINNING OF YOUR
SHOW SAY?
YOU PUT UP A PICTURE AFTER
PICTURE OF TERRIBLE CRIMINALS
WHO HAPPEN TO BE PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
NOW, WHY DON'T YOU --
>> Laura: YOU DON'T WANT THE
TRUTH.
>> NO, I -- LAURA, ANY CHANCE I
CAN GET A WORD IN EDGE WISE?
>> Laura: LIKE A VALEDICTORIAN
RESCUING A PUPPY OR A CAT FROM A
TREE, THAT'S YOUR STORY.
MY STORY IS THE AMERICAN VICTIMS
WHO YOU AND SO MANY DEMOCRATS
NEVER PAY ATTENTION TO, AND OF
COURSE THERE ARE GOOD PEOPLE WHO
ARE --
>> LAURA, WHY DO YOU INVITE ME
ON THE SHOW IF I'M NOT ALLOWED
TO SAY ANYTHING?
LAURA, ANY CHANCE --
>> Laura: GO AHEAD.
>> THE FALSEHOOD IS THAT
IMMIGRANTS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY --
11 MILLION PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY WITHOUT DOCUMENTS, AND
YOU ARE SHOWING PICTURES OF SOME
MORE TERRIBLE CRIMINALS.
>> Laura: HOW DO YOU KNOW HOW
MANY?
>> WE HAVE PRETTY GOOD
ESTIMATES.
YOU CAN'T CERTAINLY SEND OUT A
QUESTIONNAIRE AND FIND OUT HOW
MANY IMMIGRANTS THERE ARE
WITHOUT DOCUMENTS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: HOW DO WE GET IT?
>> WE HAVE VERY GOOD ESTIMATORS.
WE HAVE -- LOOK, YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A COUNTRY THAT HAS AN
INTELLIGENCE WORLDWIDE.
WE CERTAINLY CAN COME RELATIVELY
CLOSE TO DETERMINING HOW MANY
THERE ARE.
AND, LO, YOU WANT TO SAY 10 TO
12, GO RIGHT AHEAD.
I'M SAYING 11, YOU SAY 10 TO
12 -- CAN I GET A WORD IN EDGE
WISE HERE?
SPIN WE DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY, THAT'S ONE OF THE
POINTS.
>> WE CERTAINLY CAN FIND OUT
THROUGH THE SENSES.
THE PURPOSE OF THE CENSUS
QUESTION IS TO DESTROY THE
CENSUS, GETTING PEOPLE TO IGNORE
THE FACT THAT CRIME IS COMMITTED
BY ALL GROUPS >> Laura: WE
NEED MORE CRIME POSTMARKED THAT
SUCH A BAD ARGUMENT.
>> EVERY 10 MILLION PEOPLE --
LOOK, YOU HAVE MORE CRIME IN
CALIFORNIA THAN WYOMING BECAUSE
YOU HAVE MORE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THAN IN WYOMING.
EVERY GROUP OF 10 MILLION
PEOPLE -- COAT >> Laura: GOING
TO TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TONIGHT THAT
BECAUSE OF THAT, WE HAVE TO
SACRIFICE A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
AMERICANS FOR THIS UTOPIAN IDEA
THAT BORDERS ARE POINTLESS, THAT
WALLS ARE BAD, THAT THE RULE OF
LAW, WHEN APPLIED TO A FAMILY
CROSSING THE BORDER, YOU CAN'T
SUPPORT THEM --
>> ANY CHANCE I COULD GET A WORD
IN?
>> Laura: I JUST THINK IT'S
NOT A GREAT ARGUMENT.
WE WANT LAW AND ORDER --
>> LAURA, WHY DO YOU EVEN NEED
ME ON THE SHOW?
IT'S YOUR SHOW, YOU CAN JUST
TALK.
THE FACT IS, IF YOU WANT LESS
CRIME, MOVED TO THE CAYMAN
ISLANDS.
GOT SO FEW PEOPLE THERE THAT YOU
CAN GO A WHOLE WEEK WITHOUT THE
VIOLENT CRIME.
>> Laura: IS THAT YOUR
ARGUMENT?
>> IMMIGRANTS OR ANY GROUP OF
PEOPLE -- IF YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY --
'S SPOON ILLEGAL IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> EVERY GROUP COMMITS SOME
CRIME, AND IF YOU HAD TO -- ANY
CHANCE I COULD GET A WORD IN
HERE?
THEN HAVE FEWER PEOPLE.
>> Laura: THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ILLEGAL AND
LEGAL.
DO YOU NOT KNOW THE DIFFERENCE?
DOES IT MATTER?
>> ANY CHANCE I CAN GET A WORD
IN?
THE FACT IS --
>> Laura: YOU CAN TALK DURING
A PAUSE.
THE CENSUS ASKS QUESTIONS ABOUT
CITIZEN STATUS, HAS IT NOT?
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE, THEY STOPPED
IN 1950.
THEY STOPPED ABOUT THE TIME I
WAS 4 YEARS OLD AND BEFORE YOU
WERE BORN.
>> Laura: AND THEN THE
AMERICAN FAMILY SURVEY --
>> IT IS NOT USED AS THE
OFFICIAL ENUMERATION.
THE ENUMERATION OF THIS COUNTRY
IS CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED,
AND GETTING AN ACCURATE COUNT
AND ENUMERATION IS MORE
IMPORTANT, IS CONSTITUTIONALLY
MORE IMPORTANT THAN HAVING FACTS
ABOUT HOW MANY BEDROOMS THERE
ARE AND HOW MANY BATHROOMS ARE
IN EVERY HOUSE.
THAT WOULD BE GIVEN SECONDARY
PRIORITY TWO.
>> Laura: IT SO SO YOU ILLEGL
IMMIGRANTS SHOULD BE ACCOUNTING
FOR THE APPORTIONMENT OF THE
NUMBER OF LEGISLATURES --
>> THE CONSTITUTION SAYS THAT.
FELONS CAN'T VOTE.
THEY HAVE TO BE COUNTED.
>> Laura: RIGHT, SO YOU ARE
SAYING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE
CITIZENS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
APPORTIONMENT CLAUSE.
THERE IS A DEBATE ABOUT THAT IN
LEGAL CIRCLES.
>> THE CONSTITUTION SAYS THAT.
THE SUPREME COURT SAYS THAT.
THE AVID CASE REACHED THAT
CONCLUSION.
AND IF YOU WANT TO REVERSE THAT,
FINE.
TRY TO PASS A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT.
TRY TO REVERSE THE DECISION.
DON'T POLLUTE THE CENSUS IN AN
EFFORT TO ACHIEVE CONSTITUTIONAL
RESULTS THAT YOU CAN'T ACHIEVE
THROUGH THE COURTS.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE TO RESPOND
TO THE SENSES, SO PEOPLE AREN'T
GOING TO RESPOND, IT'S ANOTHER
REASON THEY ARE BREAKING THE
LAW.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
TO GET EVERYBODY TO RESPOND TO
THE CENSUS.